hey girls
hey Cassie walk so fast sorry I'm just
so excited walking I'm excited too are
you crying already
yes of course I'm crying my babies I'm
awake help your friend out here
your friends your gal pal your girl so
cute I think that you have maybe the
worst to you I think the other the worst
attitude I think you have the worst face
I'd like to think I'd like to punch it
you have the worst breath I'd like to
cover it you have the worst outfit so
there where'd you get that outfit at the
sandwich shop I think it's crazy that
you come from California and you're like
a country let your girl out where I live
Apple Valley yep it's the high desert so
there's like a lot of property and a lot
of horses it's so weird to like
literally we drive like two hours down
to LA it's like a whole different world
I've never ridden a rode on a horse
before ever no you need to come to my
house he's all kinds of shame he's like
saying things about one person cuz he
wants the other person he is a scheming
MF Fuli I'm on this show to win I don't
care about it all exactly
don't ya oh yeah along the way I'm
trying to win the show don't care if I
hurt your feelings in the process Adam
because you have no soul woops
[Applause]
my good hands there
got it yeah you're terrible hi fathers
don't let out what ya still have new
coach blue head that was a whimper haha
country rock blues country rock blue
country Sam Blake petite country country
I wonder if Blake's somewhere not now
and trailer eating a mayonnaise sandwich
all you need sing the blues good choice
she's so awesome yay I was like I was
not a beauty cuz I thought you pushed it
further suppose I make sure there's no
somebody right she can't it was so I was
just overwhelmed I didn't know like I
was looking at him are you gonna do it
he like just had this mischievous I
thought that maybe he's not gonna do it
I feel like that was dreamy
you